hey folks and welcome to generation next
our weekly show all about the
playstation 5 and xbox series x now we
are just under a month out from both new
consoles well all three new consoles of
course we can't forget about the series
s so this week we're going to be talking
about the fact that sony has literally
broken their silence finally we've got
more hands-on impressions of the series
x as well as more backwards
compatibility details for all the
consoles joining me to break down this
news i've got the playstation pro to
more hussein
absolutely
[Music]
carnal
for these new consoles
don't like it i don't like it you know
what didn't like that one yeah gave us
something over asmr as well
i mean
yeah you did i mean i'm sure no don't
give that to you
there's a market for it there's a market
for it if anyone else wants asmr from me
just hit me up let me know in the
comments below i'll send you whatever
words you want we also have a video of
rod ferguson doing asmr if you're really
into that hi i'm ron ferguson i'm the
studio head of the coalition we make
gears 5 and today we're going to be
talking about intimate combat uh and
xbox expert jordan remains
all right so
a little bit of a peek behind the
curtain we're recording this in two
batches because uh thursday morning at
the same time as the xbox embargo the
cheeky little buggers uh sony dropped
all the information about what the user
experience is gonna be on the
playstation 5. finally we've been
clamoring for this uh piece of
information we now know what the ps5 ui
is gonna look like so um
they gave a pretty in-depth run through
apparently it is optimized for 4k which
i'm uh
my gaming mode on my tv is finally gonna
see way more action i suppose uh but tam
do you want to walk us through some of
the cool things that sony's been showing
off with regards to the ps5 ui
sure so as you said the they've seemed
to have cleaned it up the like broader
kind of takeaway is it's cleaned up
they've it's been simplified and it's
also been integrated into the play
experience in a more seamless way um so
when they press the button to which i
assume is the playstation button to
bring up the ui it wasn't like backing
out of a menu in the way that it would
on the ps4 it kind of just overlaid it
which is
a nice little touch so you get immediate
access that to pretty much everything
you would need from from the system in
that button press um and that stuff like
you can work on audio levels you can
access the power you can see like
controller battery levels microphone
that kind of stuff check data stuff uh
download um status and that kind of
business but the important stuff is the
cards that's uh laid out along the
bottom um in the control center is what
they're calling it so that's really
interesting it feels like a dynamic
thing and also feels like something that
developers can program in and it is
geared towards improving and enhancing
your gameplay experience so one of the
things they showed off that is that you
can
discover new gameplay opportunities
and basically what that means is like
the game will tell tell you like hey you
could do this right now or hey you you
almost finished doing this maybe you
should do it and it will take you
another 10 minutes to complete this
which is
a step above like the trophy tracking
stuff that we asked for it's also got
like mission tracking and like gameplay
timer tracking which i'm sure will
factor into like parental controls in an
interesting way as well where a parent
can roll up and be like looks like this
mission should take you 15 minutes so do
this one
and then just this one mission before
bed look mom the playstation says it's
only going to take 10 minutes that's
actually i mean i never even thought of
it that way that's a really cool thing
it's really going to be i'm interested
how they do it and then like the other
big thing that um was was impressive was
they've um enhanced and tweaked the
party format um so you can get people
together and you can chat and the other
thing you can do is like if someone is
sharing their gameplay you can watch
their game play picture in picture while
you're playing a game
which is
huge well first of all what they've done
is they've brought back xbox's one of my
favorite ever features on xbox
uh the snap
so not only can you do picture in
picture but you can also like have your
friends
game play and also walkthroughs they're
putting walkthroughs
into the playstation so if you ever get
stuck there's like dynamic walkthroughs
that you can pin
and they're like putting it in a really
cool way the the interesting thing is
like i think that's fantastic one of the
things they said is like they alluded to
a media tab as well but they were like
we're not going to talk about that right
now we'll talk about that later so that
will be all the streaming video stuff if
i already hope there is and it makes
perfect sense that there is the ability
to launch apps um you know
picture-in-picture in the way that snap
was so i want to be able to have
netflix running at the same time as a
game you know and like maybe control the
audio balance between them i hope that's
the thing that they have figured out and
they are able to because if they do that
that's massive for us like as people who
play so many games as a service things
and also like cover movies tv that kind
of business and uh you know as anyone
would being able to multitask in that
way would be incredible i'd love to be
able to watch something while i'm
grinding through mementos in persona 5
royal
[Music]
band
saying and then yeah the hints and
walkthrough stuff that you mentioned can
be pinned and
one of the things to keep in mind is
like uh it's unclear now how much of
that is like uh executing that is
reliant on developers
putting it in how much of it is like
users can do it will they be able to in
the same way that stadia promised like
grab any sort of like youtube video
and do it so
it kind of in the same way for like the
cards like how long before you know it
is very much
reliant on developers putting in the
extra effort so i hope sony is out there
with a big old stick being like if you
don't do this they're gonna hit you with
this stick that's a bad one but i mean
it makes sense for games like uh sac boy
but can you really see demon souls cause
i feel like that's kind of the complete
antithesis of those games there is like
there's obviously cooperation to an
extent with like leaving messages on the
ground and it has a big community online
but i wonder if for some games having
hints directly within the game also
locked behind ps plus too um which has
been something that's been sticking in a
lot of people's crawls like
it's i mean i guess you're not taking
away the free
walk throughs that are online but having
in-game stuff locked behind ps plus but
like a game like demon souls i do wonder
how much
but i mean i guess if like
it'll work yeah because you could like
point to like maybe a really good weapon
that's kind of hidden or something like
that i think it's an easier maybe not
easier but a new way to make very
difficult games possibly more
approachable to new audiences it's like
oh here are some hints to maybe help you
out and try to get to certain areas
there's so much potential for this
especially the picture-in-picture stuff
like i'd like like the idea of like you
playing a game and then someone being
like i'm really stuck in this demon
souls moment and just hit a button and
it pops up their feet and you can be
like take the next left watch out for
the enemy over there and the weapon you
need but also like
that's what i'll be doing when i play
yeah we'll just be dialing you in
but what does that mean for multiplayer
games like if you're in the middle of a
multiplayer game and someone else in
your party's dead does that lead to like
cheating where you're like oh just share
your screen so i can see what you see
and like if someone's in like a death
cam mode like roaming around like the
enemy's hair and you can like look in
the corner of your screen and like
pinpoint accuracy in a way that
developers probably didn't intend for
what does that mean stream sniping from
stream sniping from within the
playstation unreal
all right i thought about that i'm about
to start playing apex legends that's
fine
but no i mean like other cool things
that they mentioned so uh
like i we've talked about this at length
but like right now getting screenshots
from the ps4 is a real struggle like
mine really chugs the way that they were
walking through doing it on ps5 it just
seemed so quick and easy and you can
immediately review them
and
if you send it to someone who you're in
a party with because parties have been
really beefed up and they're more like
message threads or like discords i guess
now uh if you send it to someone and
that person isn't at that point in the
game it'll mark it as a spoiler for them
and it won't show it to them which is so
good yeah like what a real cool quality
of life then but also one final thing i
should definitely shout out um
is that the dual sense does text to
speech and it's hopefully like it does
it really well i just i just hope that
if i like i'm using a controller this is
my phone i don't have a dual sensor but
like
it doesn't make me do that thing where
it's like oh maybe you want to
use your your thing like this to
put text in i'm i'm excited for that
because one thing i've started doing
recently is replying to text using my
watch apple watch which is really handy
and it's surprisingly accurate um so i'm
excited for doing that but i'm also
excited for like replying or like just
sending messages of me screaming after
being killed like and i i do imagine
like how how the you know the rage is
online uh how quick you know the moment
you you kill someone on an online
multiplayer and it's like a 10 year old
kid you know within a minute they're
gonna send you a message being like just
full of swear words now it's gonna be
even quicker like you're gonna get that
message within seconds there's gonna be
a five-year-old cussing out your entire
family and threatening to kill you
within moments
love to see it
well
i but we should probably talk briefly um
just about the uh the little pebbles
that started this avalanche of ps5 news
and that was the burger king himself
crumbs
crumbs
that started this
whopper
of news week
wow
wow you're really stressed for that one
i don't go burger king but it does work
uh so a few days ago they released this
um little teaser trailer on twitter of
uh what was assume everyone assumes is
the well we now know it's the ps5
startup sound and then they had a date
10
15
u.s so backwards four thursday no it's
not backwards don't do it don't do it
you're outnumbered backwards don't do it
thursday the 15th of october
and so
uh
we knew that there would be this
competition but i guess i guess people
were hoping and dreaming that there
would be some kind of news drop on the
on the 15th and it was so we've seen the
ui we know what the sound effect sounds
like but also there is a burger king
sweet the bk sweepstakes uh you can win
a thousand well you can't win a thousand
consoles you there are a thousand two
one person it will win one thousand
consoles welcome to my throne of
playstation fives uh also game codes for
demon souls and sac boy as well as ps
now codes which is good because if you
don't have a playstation you can still
use that on your pc um but also another
little look courtesy of burger king
my lord the burger lord the burger lord
um got a look at the box
what's in the box well we know
it's a playstation but you have all
these people hugging and hugging the box
so did they do they say whether you have
to do that in store
no you could do it on the app but you
just have to make a purchase jordan are
you gonna because i know you haven't
managed to get your ps5 yet are you
gonna yeah because apparently burger
king just like is hoarding all of them
that's why i couldn't just secure you
know what they say the burger lord
giveth and the burger lord taketh away
what does he give us oh burgers
yeah burgers and playstations
that's why he's the burglar
xbox have announced a bunch of
improvements that they'll be making to
backwards compatibility uh do you want
to talk us through it
yeah so they basically listed
all of the improvements that are going
to happen to your older games the xbox
one 360 original xbox games when they're
played on series x it's like auto hdr so
like if you're
if the if the game ships without hdr
enhancements it's going to
kind of still get that improvement like
the game is still going to look really
good so if all those like rumors of a
mass effect legendary like edition are
fake i'll still be able to do it play
mass effect in like its most brilliant
form on xbox series x
high dynamic range oh it'll be beautiful
it'll look so good all those elevator
rides but regardless of reductions in
load times double the frame rates that
they use the fallout 4 as uh an example
like enhanced visuals basically whatever
older game that you're playing on series
x it's going to look
better like what was that game that jeff
keeley kept playing blinks
yeah yeah and then like it got mentioned
in a blog post somewhere and i was like
goddammit is that why he was playing
that particular old game i mean blinks
is an xbox meme so i'm not surprised
that kiwi's on it
meme lord jeff keely wow going from one
meme lord to another oh but in terms of
actually like
listing out how
backwards compatibility works on xbox
they've made it
super bloody easy jordan you wanna tell
us about to say yeah it's like if you
have it on disk you put the disk in and
it will play and it will look really
pretty and if you don't have the disc
but you have the digital copy you just
download it again and you can just play
it like if you have the game it's going
to be really easy to access you don't
have to like jump through any hoops to
play your old library of games uh and
tam will come to you for playstation
because they also revealed their
backwards compatibility uh kind of faq
similarly to xbox it seems like it's
gonna be pretty easy but there are a
number of caveats
um
to do with certain games but i'll let
you talk us through it yeah so it's all
fairly simple and the caveats aren't
generally like negative caveats for the
most part the sony stuff is great news
um i'm really excited to see um both
microsoft and sony taking backwards
compatibility very seriously this time
around at least for the last gen of
games so
as previously messaged more than 99 of
ps4 games will be playable on ps5
there's actually like a very small
handful of games that aren't playable
and if you if these are games that you
care about i'm very sorry but
i have i am like not shedding any tears
for any of these so i was gonna i was
gonna go pro in
um so the games are going to quickly
rattle them off because there's not that
many he's dwvr
i got a clue what that is like
i assume it's a dw from the hit animated
show arthur in vr um afro samurai 2
revenge of kumar volume 1. did volume 2
ever come out who knows it's a mystery
tt isle of man right on the edge too
don't put again
yeah don't put a game called i love man
right on the edge together just don't do
it um deal with it uh i will shadow
complex remastered robinson the journey
um we sing hit mango uh my favorite
fruit uh shordens joe's diner that's it
i don't know like that's fine so digital
games will work on ps5 when you sign up
um they say uh you'll be able to autumn
automatically see uh your library there
i see the official sony no that's my one
that's what i've called it i assume when
you sign in as well it's the same all
your games that you own digitally will
just pop up and they've said like select
games will see increased loading speed
um better frame rate and some of them
will have like game boosting um to
improve that frame rate but not
everything
select ps4 games uh
we'll have that um so some games will
also take advantage of the ps5 new ux
features vr support is included for a
bunch of games uh remote player from ps4
to ps5 and ps now streaming is supported
um but ps4 game streaming doesn't use
the game boost so if you have a game
that presumably takes advantage of game
boost and try streaming it for a ps now
on ps5 it won't use that uh save
transfers fairly simple to digital games
digital game day and game saves from ps4
to ps5 can be moved over using a lan
cable wi-fi or if you've got it on a usb
device and then you can also sync ps4
saves through cloud storage which is
excellent fantastic
and then specifically they call out for
marvel spider-man miles morales when
players decide to upgrade from ps4 to
ps5 the game saves will transfer over
sac boy a big adventure will also
support game save transfers from ps4 to
ps5 in an update that will be delivered
shortly after
excuse me while i burp the release of
the game so sony basically said it's all
good but then explained everything in
niagara east in a way that couldn't seem
quite scary but the the for the most
large majority of people chances are
this is exactly what you want your games
are going to be playable your saves will
transfer over some way or the other and
there's methods to upgrade from disk to
you know uh
to when you get a new ps5 disk version
or digital to digital i was let's say
like isn't it so nice that for like the
first time both xbox and playstation are
handling backwards compatibility like
relatively easily like there's really no
fuss this time around we're just going
to be able to play all of our old games
super easy i love it i don't get rid of
anything well the only the only fuss
will come is if you have a load of
playstation 4 discs and you get the ps5
digital edition yeah because obviously
you need need your disk honestly like
but like that's a poor decision on your
that's just
you if you have done that not knowing
shout out to you i don't know how you
pull that off
all right so
we had another embargo lift uh the final
preview of the xbox series x so
ordinarily we would have michael heim on
to answer all your burning questions but
he is understandably
just
chin
chin deep
uh in xbox coverage right now so we've
taken his preview he's got it written up
on site he has a separate video which
came out yesterday uh we'll link it if
you want to go see his in-depth um
like final impressions of the series x
um if you have any questions for him let
us know we'll get them on hopefully next
week um but also
let's just list out some of the very
very interesting takeaways from his
final hands-on preview so
one big thing that people were
questioning is how hot does the series x
get
apparently
very quite quite hot very quiet yeah
[Music]
oh that's hot
that's hot that's unsurprising like uh i
don't think anyone expected it to be
like cool the entire time given how
powerful the hardware is in there and
how how much hard work is putting in i
think the big takeaway is yes it's going
to get hot so you need to be more
mindful than ever of your ventilation
space yeah i've been talking with people
about that who are already a bit
concerned about where their xboxes are
gonna go
um
but jordan let's talk briefly because
a little a little tangent based on what
sony's doing so obviously the
ps5 is massive
um
but it's because of the fan so when we
saw in the teardown video that fan
fat fan fat fan
that's what i wrote it down in my notes
only fans
that's all i got there's no there's no
more to that
i didn't know how to follow it up no
there was nothing perfect
we were talking last week about how big
the playstation 5 is and it turns out
that the size of the console is because
of that big thick fat fan so speaking uh
to nikkei's x tech which is a japanese
publication
we have otori
yasuhiro
head of ps5's mechanical and thermal
design team
uh explained that
it was possible to develop the
playstation 5 to be smaller
one of the examples they gave was
implement two cooling fans one for side
and one for side b um if they had done
that the ps5 would have been much
smaller um
but
there would be an additional cost so
technically
um yeah that makes sense one fan is
cooler than two um and so you just have
to kind of deal with a much bigger
console so that was that was translated
uh by video games chronicle i want to
give them the props for that but it's
very interesting to see that like
i don't know i didn't realize that heat
was going to be such a big talking point
this gen did you i think yeah yeah it's
i mean i don't think it was
we could have predicted it but like i'm
glad it is because that's a big part of
keeping that's my one of my big worries
for consoles generally is like how do
they over time
you know degrade and
going the extra mile early on to ensure
that cooling is a major part of its
architecture it just gives me a little
more confidence that you know i you know
four years into the life cycle of a ps5
i won't be needing to buy a new one
because the fan is buggered or like the
vents are all clogged up and i need to
open it up um at least that's the hope
who knows but yeah i'm glad that cooling
is a big topic of discussion right now
yeah and i mean sony microsoft make your
consoles like i won't say as big as you
want i live in a small apartment i have
limited space but if you have to make
your consoles a lot bigger in order to
include a larger fan to keep it cool and
hopefully
quiet
quiet like
that's all i want like i'm using my ps4
pro and like i have really big hair
headphones are not like an option for me
and so i please as as long as the
console is quiet i don't care if you
create these giant obelisks of consoles
i'll find space for it i will just as
long as the fan runs quiet speaking of
obelisk did you see that in microsoft
flight simulator they've put a series x
in oh yeah
you're a 5000 series
a fan did that not not much oh this
isn't
much it was like a fan made solo it's
even better yeah it's massive it's huge
uh all right another takeaway from
michael's preview uh let's talk about
quick resume so obviously that uh first
embargo we had we got to see quick
resume in action he had something like
five or six games running at once i was
just hopping between them all
one really bloody cool thing that he can
now talk about is that even if you
unplug your console quick resume still
works i don't know how but that's so
cool that it does that that's like magic
and what does it remember
i don't know but given i mean i don't
know where you guys live but right now
we've been getting a lot of power
outages like
that's really cool
yeah i i think like the i mean i guess
it kind of works
somewhat like the system restore on it
on a
pc where it's actively making kind of
like restore points and that kind of
stuff but
the fact that it's doing stuff around
that is so so cool especially like lucy
said with things like power cuts being a
worry and and you know
family members who might just suddenly
accidentally unplug it by family members
i mean like cats and stuff for dogs or
whatever it may be or disgruntled
partners you know yeah yeah if you have
a partner who's just like enough gaming
and they rip the quarter you can just
look at them and go you think you can
hurt me
no this is a quick result
yeah you think that all you've done
is create a save restore point for me
also we're breaking up get out
you can't pause a multiplayer game i
told you anyways there's another cool
feature also uh jordan you wanna talk to
us about
load times because we we saw that first
embargo we actually have a video of it
up uh on a gamespot of load times on
games like red dead two
final fantasy and the outer were urls
[Laughter]
outer world um and you get to see the
improvement uh with those games running
on series x but they were obviously
running on the internal hard drive
now we've got details about stuff that's
running on external i would say uh i'm
basically going to just quote from
michael here because he can explain this
way
better than i can but like so
essentially just in terms of like data
and loading so michael tested using a
samsung t5 external ssd and a usb 3.1
cable and
the results were good like the outer
worlds is a 45 gigabyte game and it took
2 minutes 54 seconds to move it to the
external ssd like that's
incredibly fast that's
you can't do that on uh xbox one x right
now you just you can't do it but that's
just yeah and when loading the same save
as previous test it only took 13 seconds
which is extremely close to internal ssd
speeds yeah so originally it was um
loading on xbox one x it was 43 seconds
series x 11 seconds and so on the
internal ssd so on the external for it
to only be 13 seconds two seconds
difference
like i was really worried it was going
to be a very very noticeable difference
but that is so
negligible that
that's super impressive it's like that's
that's not even enough time to like do a
quick doom scroll through twitter or
something like that like
is that the official new measurement
yeah that's what i use a doom scroll
quick doomscore yeah i mean like that's
going to be like those those transfer
speeds are going to be just work wonders
for people's mental health in over the
next generation just saving us from
twitter
opening twitter and being like goddammit
and i'm putting it down again and i
think like the the important thing is
the reason why that works is because it
is still using the the the power of the
nvme uh ssd on the xbox series x you're
either taking away from it or putting on
to it so there's some
you know one part of that pipeline is
incredibly fast still even if the other
part is like not as matched so having
that internal ssd paying off yet again
to wrap up let's discuss ui so
uh this actually links into xbox one and
ps4 a little bit because both consoles
are getting uh big system updates this
week so xbox one the ui update is coming
to kind of bring it more in line with
what the series x ui is gonna look like
and per michael's preview he says that
it doesn't actually look that much
different the main difference is that
it's much easier to navigate thank god
look look
it's not great or it wasn't it used to
be really bad it's definitely had
improvements and so i'm excited to see
what this new one is like uh the main
takeaway that michael said is that the
boot up is super quick and like honestly
already on my one x it's already quick
so i'm very excited to see that got a
video up right now but if you have a one
uh or one x
or a 1s you should be able to get that
update this week so as i said earlier if
you have questions for michael about the
series x make sure to drop them in the
comments we'll ask him very nicely next
week um time where can people find you
you find me on twitter tomorrow h
tweeting about the burger lord and ps5
um yeah jordan what about you you can
find me on twitter at jm remain getting
excited for that apex legend season
seven and seeing that mass effect rumors
are coming back up again getting to
november getting to that in seven days
it's time to get hyped once more oh it's
like uh the bit from futurama was like
you erased my hopes and crushed them
quite spectacularly so that's me every
n7 day uh i'm on twitter at least james
games
tweeting about
uh just bad jokes probably we'll see you
next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh and tam will come to you for
playstation because they also revealed
their backwards compatibility uh kind of
faq
similarly to xbox it seems like it's
gonna be pretty easy but there are a
number of caveats
um
to do with certain games but i'll let
you talk us through it
have that
please don't
[Laughter]
i have some of that
i thought that like
i thought that i
messed up and that i'd done the throw
really badly because you just went um
i thought you were about to like exclaim
and talk about something like really
important or bad or like i don't think
the ps5 like backwards compatibility is
like worthy of a rant or anything no i
think